hella in New York badass low-key
twirling knives Valkyrie scenes and
alternate end credits are just a few of
the things cut from the theatrical
release of thor ragnarok yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
discussing Thor Ragnarok deleted and
alternate scenes reshoots rejected
concepts and everything else we never
got to see in the third Thor movie while
you hear my Thor Ragnarok giveaway is
still running so for your chance to win
a Ragnarok Funko pop or a very cool
obsessed with Marvel book just make sure
you're subscribed to my channel and
leave a comment below with your thoughts
about the movie or the deleted scenes
obviously I'll be talking spoilers so
take care if you haven't seen the film
yet ok let's start with the deleted
scenes from the trailers that never made
it into the final movie the most
significant change is the scene of hella
destroying Thor's hammer the setting for
which was moved from New York to Norway
reshooting the scene was much more
important than it might at first appear
because it completely changed how the
movie dealt with Odin and his death
during the film's production set photos
popped up of Anthony Hopkins dressed as
a hobo at the time it was reported that
in the film we discover that after Loki
had usurped Odin from his throne on
Asgard Odin had escaped to earth where
he was wandering the streets of New York
panelist making dire predictions of the
end of the world in the final movie
however we discovered that Odin is in
Norway instead contemplating life in a
field overlooking the sea director Taika
Waititi has explained that he moved the
location to Norway because it felt like
a more appropriate setting for Odin to
have a heart-to-heart talk with his sons
before he died ytt also implied that
perhaps feedback from test screenings
was that the audience didn't understand
why character as powerful as Odin was
now a homeless person bumbling around
New York so the director felt that an
open green field in Norway was more
respectful of the mighty King Odin the
location also ties in with real-world
Norse legends which are of course the
basis for the Thor Marvel verse I also
like the way that when Odin died his
body evaporated into flecks of light
mirroring what happened to his wife Riga
during her ceremonial funeral in Thor
the dark world I can see that this is a
much more noble death for the former
king of Asgard than perishing on the
streets of New York the alleyway scene
in New York was pretty cool in the
trailer though and did a great job of
hyping fans for the movie Eve
if the reshot scene was more appropriate
in the context of the film and that's
not the only great moment in the trailer
that ended up being chopped from the
movie this several moments cut from the
final showdown on the Rainbow Bridge
including the four avengers squaring off
against Heller sadly in the final film
we never saw our four heroes lineup like
this instead there was one moment of
Thor Valkyrie and Loki together but Hulk
was busy battling Fenris wolf at the
time it also looks like some extended
fight scenes with Heller might have been
chopped as I don't think this shot of
Heller spinning and sending out a swirl
of knives made it in and this iconic
shot of hallorann f-full headgear
turning slowly to the camera appears to
have inked hurt from Valkyries flashback
scene now there's a very intriguing
deleted scene with Loki twirling a pair
of knives on a bridge it feels like this
might have been part of a longer deleted
scene where Loki helped douse Guardian
refugees down from their Mountain
shelter to the Rainbow Bridge where the
rescue ship was waiting loki did get
some good action scenes in the final
battle but it still feels a shame we
never saw this moment I'm guessing it
was cut for time though to prevent the
final showdown from getting too long
speaking of Loki in an early story draft
that was going to be more of the god of
mischief via some flashback scenes to a
young Loki antagonizing his brother Thor
the tone that Taika Waititi wanted for
those flashbacks were similar to the
classic 80s films of writer director
John Hughes such as sixteen Candles one
of the flashbacks would have popped up
during the scene on Sokka where Loki is
tied up in Valkyrie banner and Thora all
talking about how he wants to kill them
which leads Thor to recount the time
when he and Loki were eight years old
and Loki transformed himself into a
snake before quickly transforming back
and stabbing Thor a flashback here could
have been a fun moment but according to
ITT in the end it was one thing too many
to add to the movie and the story was
funnier the way Chris Hemsworth told it
ytt also revealed to MTV that another
John Hughes inspired scene ended up cut
from the movie the idea was that when
Thor and Balki met in the film they
realized they already knew each other
then there was going to be a flashback
to 1980s Asgard where everyone had
mullets and wore his shoulder pads in
the cutscene Thor was going to be an
overweight child who was being picked on
by
the kids and Loki would have been an emo
goth character a bit like Draco Malfoy
from Harry Potter the problem with this
scene was that in the final story they
needed Thor not to have met Valkyrie
before so the flashback wouldn't have
worked there's also a deleted promo
scene between Doctor Strange and Thor at
strangers sanctum sanctorum destiny has
dire plans for you my friend
I have dire plans for destiny I wonder
if this deleted scene suggests that
Doctor Strange has some foreknowledge of
the events of Ragnarok that are about to
be unleashed there's also a nice Star
Wars esque shot and line that was teased
in the trailer but ended up cut from the
movie as well in an interview with
Rolling Stone Tessa Thompson who plays
Valkyrie revealed that his scene
alluding to her character's bisexuality
was cut from the final film Thompson
said that after researching her
character in the comics she learned
about Valkyries relationship with
archaeologist Annabelle Riggs so she
convinced ytt to film a scene of a woman
leaving her bedroom implying the two had
been intimate however according to the
interview the moment was deleted because
it took focus away from the main
narrative at the time but with Valkyrie
back for a small role and Avengers
infinity war and thompson having
recently pitched an all-female team up
movie to marvel Valkyrie sexuality could
be something that's addressed in a
future movie and talking a female
Asgardian warriors one fan favorite
missing from the third movie is Lady SIF
Jamie Alexander recently confirmed that
she was indeed asked to return to the
role but scheduling conflicts with her
TV series blind spots meant she couldn't
make it
the curious thing though is back in 2015
Jamie Alexander said she would
definitely be back for the latest Thor
film and that she would have a pivotal
role this makes me wonder whether at
that time Valkyrie wasn't supposed to
feature in the movie or at least not as
heavily and whether the original plan
was perceived to play a part similar to
that instead I guess Alexander's lead in
blind spot the first two seasons of
which are over 20 episodes meant it was
too hard to give SIF a major role in the
new film but at least sifts absence
means she wasn't killed off by Heller
has happened to the Warriors three
so SIF could still reappear in the MCU
which Alexander says she'll be very
happy to do this array bill is a popular
character from the comics and although
an Easter Egg to him virus statue
outside the Grand Master's palace he
never actually appears in the movie
according to Kevin Feige though at one
point beater a bill was going to be in
the film however they felt they weren't
doing his character justice so they
can't his appearance altogether and just
left the easter egg though they may well
introduce him in a later movie Heller
was one of the highlights of Thor
Ragnarok thanks to an interesting
backstory great Swagger and an actress
to match she's also the first female
lead villain in an MCU movie however
Taika Waititi revealed that another
Marvel Comics villain called paratus was
originally going to be in the film ytt
didn't elaborate on whether the
character would have been instead of
heller
however it's interesting that paratus
who's a much more obscure villain shares
some similar comic-book history to
Heller's arc in Thor Ragnarok in the
comics paratus is a dark God who's
defeated by Odin when he and the other
dark gods attack as God to punish para
cos Odin imprisons him in a special cell
in a distant part of the universe that
only the all-father has access to in a
similar way to how he keeps heller
locked away in the MCU also like Heller
paratus destroyed Thor's hammer when he
chomped it in half in the comics some of
the parallels between the two characters
are close enough that I wonder how much
para cos provided inspiration for
Heller's backstory in the movie I'm
still glad that Heller was a final
choice though if she gave us one of the
better MCU villains so far and I'm also
really glad she didn't end up being the
villain in Thor the dark world as was
originally going to be the case
another Ragnarok highlight is Jeff
Goldblum's take on the Grand Master with
the veteran actor bringing some great
off-the-wall humor to his eccentric
Sekar and dictator however if you look
at the comic book version of his
character you'll notice he has blue skin
according to Taika Waititi the reason
for the change in the movie was that
Goldblum already played the part of a
blue alien in the 1988 sci-fi musical
comedy earth girls are easy still
Ragnarok does include some little
allusions to the grandmasters original
comic book look with blue eyeliner and a
little blue strip on his face which is
also a nod to the fact he's related to
the MC news collector set visits for
Thor Ragnarok also reported seeing
concept art of a meeting between the
Grand Master and guardians of the galaxy
character the broker in the first
guardians movie the broker planned to
buy the orb which contained the power
stone for the
lector / film also reported that an item
courtesan durian cube was found on the
propolis in the movies production office
and that concept art of the Guardians
Milano ship was found on set as well
none of these Guardians connections
ended up in the movie and I wonder if
they were possibly infinity stone
related in some way cookie of Infinity
stones Marvel fans waiting for the final
reveal of the soul stone and thor
ragnarok were disappointed there were
hints and theories that seeing Halla
bathed in orange light after destroying
Thor's hammer and the trailers indicated
she'd acquired the soul stone for Mele
near but with that scenery shot and
relocated it's possible though not
especially likely that Marvel midway
through production decided to remove any
soul stone connection in the movie there
is however speculation the soul stone
was in the eternal flame which brought
Serta back to life at the end of the
film and that this could tie in with
Alice's arrival at the very end in the
mid credits and on the subjective and
credit scenes Jeff Goldblum told Digital
Spy that thanks to Taika Waititi strong
preference for improvisation on set they
filmed around 20 different versions of
his post-credits scene some of them
include the Grandmaster trying to start
a new revolution to overthrow the
current revolution and in another he
starts singing the Saqqara national
anthem speaking to Fandango ytt also
said there was an extended version of
the melt stick scene featuring the
Grandmaster speaking at length to his
cousin Carlo before he zaps him and in
the scenes at the arena there were much
lengthier versions of the Grand Master's
speeches to the crowd during which
Goldblum riffed on all kinds of subjects
at my titi threw at him including
licensing a car plus is a deleted scene
involving mine between the Grand Master
and topaz after he sends Loki and Bal
curry off to find Thor and the Hulk
whitey T's emphasis on improvised comedy
and thor ragnarok means we can probably
expect a lot of unused comedic gem some
of which will hopefully appear on the
blu-ray and DVD now what do you think
about any of the deleted scenes or
things which didn't make it into thor
ragnarok is there anything you wish had
been included or are you happy with the
final movie let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe for your chance to win a
marvel Funko pop or and obsessed with
Marvel book I'll announce the winners on
my upcoming Justice League videos so
turn on your notifications to get those
as soon as I post them if you enjoyed
this then do hit that like
button and check out more of my marvel
and deleted scenes videos right here
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers